ich glaube keiner wirklich so wie
krieger das wasser gemisch würde bis
mache ich glaube schon wenn ein schade
denn wirklich aktiv von mir verursacht
werde ich also trage ich natürlich noch
da wo etwas also passiert einfach los
und informieren involviert oder
interveniere und entscheide somit selber
wenn es hat jedes menschlich viel wert
denn ist wenn es ganz zynisch
mathematisch und mache bin ich zwei
level menschen doppelt so viel wert als
ich weiß es nicht dass ich meine
situation nicht der einzige angebracht
hatte obwohl es natürlich wahnsinnig zu
wenig ist ich hoffe ich die situation um
schafe nicht begeistert und zum glück
ein computervirus entscheidet wer stirbt
werden